Using what we found in Google Trends,
you can further explore keyword
options using Google Keyword Planner.
Keyword Planner is an awesome tool
that's similar to Google Trends in some
ways, like identifying related keywords
and seeing historical statistics.
But the biggest difference is we get to
narrow down options by their performance
and what we can afford.
This will help us make
our plan more realistic.
And we'll support our
decision about keywords and
budget when we build
our ad words campaign.
Now the biggest takeaways for
keyword planner are first
expanding your keyword options.
Based on your first set of keywords from
Google Trends, you can get ideas to more
relevant keywords, and hopefully ones
you haven't actually thought of before.
Second, you can use it as a simulation.
For different bids, budgets and learn
what estimated number of clicks and
conversions you might get
from certain keywords.
This will help you choose
your bid on every keyword and
plan your budget accordingly for
you AdWords campaign.
However, if your keywords are really
popular among advertisers
it might be challenging and
expensive for you to bid on clicks.
We'll learn more in lesson four about
how your placement in a search results
list is a combination of your
performance and your bid.
Now, as a beginner it's
usually pretty tricky for you.
It'll take you a while to perform
better than the existing players.
Especially if it's a crowded market,
like insurance, for example.
And obviously your advertising
budget is going to be a little bit
lower than those big name advertisers.
Make sure you're focusing on keywords
that are really specific for
your added value.
That way you'll perform better than your
competitors and have fewer competitors.
For us, for example we learned
that in Google Trends pet
care is a more popular search
term than pet sitting.
So we may want to go with that search
term and reach a bigger audience.
However the truth of the matter is,
then we would be competing with
veterinarian services, insurance for
pets and other advertisers.
Who have a much larger budget
than we do at Embarkment.
So rather than having us walk through
Google's Keyword Planner with you.
We highly encourage you to check
out Google's documentation,
it's really wonderful for
people of all skill sets.
So if you're an expert
at Keyword Planner or
just starting out, the documentation
is really easy and engaging.
There's a link to a video in the
instructor notes that talks more about
Keyword Planner as well as
a link to the documentation.
This documentation will
be endlessly helpful for
you when you're exploring keywords and
other Google tools.
It's great practice to get
comfortable exploring documentation
because technology is ever changing.